it's not just about the death the place
you go to it's the actual act of moving
is also a leap
the decision was
that i'm going to
give away my salary at mit so stop
taking salary
give away the group so students no more
research the grant funding i still keep
an mit affiliation just because i have
friends and colleagues they're still
doing research but giving away
really primarily is the source of money
so no salary and let it go to zero let
my bank account go to zero
and uh
take a leap
in san francisco
or
elsewhere
and as covid broke out
and a lot of people started talking to
me about san francisco about the
cynicism there and i'll go there and
there was a kind of
uh so it's not all the woke stuff and
all that kind of things which is also a
problem
it's less it's uh less about
dreaming about a big future about
building a big future
and more about some kind of identity
politic battles that they're just
you could say some some aspect in the
positive light is important but
in a place like silicon valley to me the
most important thing is
to do big things
and
for that to be most of the conversation
and so that cynicism was there and then
i went to look at austin and austin it
was the opposite yeah it's the optimism
and you have people like us
so elon
was uh the optimistic about
making this the capital of artificial
intelligence and technology and so on
and then um
mr joe rogan
now
just the optimism about making this the
cultural capital of the world of uh i
mean specifically comedy but like it
just radiates from just the excitement
and i've seen not many people of that
nature in my life and when i see that in
their eyes that engine that fire of
wanting to create something special
about the place
first of all those people rarely fail
that's first of all and second of all
that's contagious it's contagious yes
and so all that combined
for me uh 2021 was this the
actual leap of taking the leap saying
all right well
um i'm actually going to do this so not
just giving away the salary not giving
away all that but the whole thing
that's it you just move to a place
there's an empty building
you know and you're moving into it
um
and this is a new life and that leap i
don't know it's a scary leap to take
because i've taken that leap many times
in my life and this is where you know
parents and all those kinds of
cynicism's really destructive because
you know
um from a cynical perspective is you
know i worked at google so why leave
google there's a very high paying salary
that you can have google
then mit why leave mit
like at mit
this is you've always dreamed about like
why do you get a phd yeah you've loved
mit or why leave mit
i mean this is the same process i've
gone through with a lot of things in
life like you've been saying
every single stage and you need that
um you need friends you need support
groups and all those kinds of things
that are extremely important but in the
end it's about taking the leap
and for me 2021 was this leap and to me
that one one of the most beautiful
things you can do in life is to take
those leaps and that's something that i
think is no longer a thing in new york
there's no sense of hope you don't go to
new york now if
there's been such an assault and
intentionally or otherwise maybe it's
inevitable they didn't have a choice but
there's been such an assault on
creativity and small business in new
york
that no one or very few people who are
in new york right now think things are
going to get great soon whereas here
i feel it's every day is just something
exciting is going to happen
you